let's turn for a moment to kendall roy
my favorite white man snitchy rich or as
you may know him a jar of mayonnaise in
a prada suit
okay
yes i remember that that z-way guest
starring as a fictional version of her
real tv persona in the hit show
succession now she's back with season
two she made it of her critically
acclaimed late night variety series
guess what it's called z-way it airs on
showtime which like cbs is a division of
paramount global so in the series z-way
uses sketches sketches rather musical
performances and her signature interview
style to have some funny and often very
very uncomfortable awkward conversations
about race politics and other social
issues now in this clip she interviews
actor chet hanks he's the son of tom
hanks and rita wilson about culturally
appropriating jamaican accents
are there any marginalized communities
you want to apologize to i don't know
maybe the pothole community
no
i don't feel like i've truly done
anything offensive so
you don't see it as cultural
appropriation you see it as like a
celebration of culture
and then it's like social justice
warriors can like go kick rocks yeah
yeah
yeah
i i love chet unapologetic yeah yeah
that's how i see it that's awesome icon
honestly no no and i and listen it
doesn't bother me i like his jamaican
accent i like it when he does it but
z-way let's talk about you because the
first guest was charlemagne which i
thought was hilarious thank you because
charlemagne the god came out tony you
saw this too and he goes i said who in
the world is going to come on this show
after looking at her season one he goes
and now here my beep is sitting here
talking to you
do you ever worry about getting guests
because you do seem to thrive on making
people uncomfortable i do but i don't
worry about getting guests the people
who get it get it and those that don't
don't and those guests who buy in those
are the most fun honestly so essentially
we keep calling it uncomfortable or
awkward but when you're watching it even
though you know it's supposed to be it's
not it's actually entertaining as hell
yes it's very funny so how do you find
that balance i think i find discomfort
to be funny we exist as humans in this
world and god
i'm uncomfortable all the time and so i
just have to laugh at myself and i think
what's cool about the guests is that
they can laugh at themselves as well
like hannibal burress
you know but but it does seem to be
a shift when we look at late night james
corden just announced by the way that
he's going to be stepping down after a
year are you already putting in your
resume i was going to ask this question
where are you oh yeah we're going to
fight over this one um
no i don't who knows i want to draft you
into the movement i think you'd be a
great lead-in for this show you know
what time will tell
shout out to viacom we'll find out i
know but when you first got this job
though because you were just on
instagram putting out videos and you
caught the eye of somebody when you were
first offered the show what did you
think what did i think i thought hahaha
my plan is working
i was really excited because this had
been like 10 years of labor finally
coming to fruition in z way of the show
because you've been writing i've been
writing shows i've been working as a
writer i started writing
right after college so when i was 24
years old 25 years old for the rundown
with robin theti then diesel samaro
dickinson carton president um so i've
been working for a minute but i'm
excited to have a television show where
i get to ask wild questions like slow
walkers versus racism so when you say
versus what say that again the walkers
versus racism yes yes where do you stand
in the way who's what's worse
when you
you say 10 years of labor
what do you say 10 years of labor do you
how much of what we see when we watch
z-wave was in your head 10 years ago and
how much did you just come up with
recently i think the show grows every
year like it's so influenced by the
current climate um so the show could not
have existed 10 years ago but the vision
of it is so unique like people who
haven't seen it it's really hard to
encapsulate you've got to watch an
episode to get it right tony yeah i feel
like i'm in like the bratz doll mansion
right now with all the pink honestly
that's kind of what i inspired you
though yeah no this is like this is me i
am a living bratz doll i'm a bratz doll
with a diploma honestly and so
it's i've always had this like aesthetic
that was pink and hyper feminine and so
it was just about merging this vision
with really great talent and really
great creativity why do you say the show
couldn't have existed years ago what is
it about the climate now that makes it
perfect for you well i did this as a
youtube series and it got 10 views and
then those same clips that are on
youtube with 100 views now have a four
million on tick tock right what's so
changed for you i think that the moment
in american history where we're suddenly
talking about race and political climate
has really met like the culture of my
show see way people are so afraid of
race your first episode is critical race
theory yes it makes people so
uncomfortable and that seems to be
something
you go to that like catnip let's go
there i'm addicted to making people
uncomfortable i guess yeah so people who
get it
get it and they're willing to be guests
yeah is there somebody out there who you
really hope gets it and you want them on
the show i mean kim kardashian is my
dream guest ellen is a dream guest
elizabeth holmes is a dream guest i
watch the dropout and i love how long
she talks i think it's very fascinating
i have so many questions for her and her
blogger
uh we're trying to get her too so good
yeah man yeah yeah let me know when you
figure it out yeah yeah elon musk he's
an african-american that i respect
why why are you guys laughing
no reason
have you put in a request to the
african-american that you respect that
is elon musk well i'm on his twitter so
hopefully he sees he sees me tweeting at
him do you ever have regrets that do you
ever think oh that went a little too far
is there any topic that you think i need
to stay away from do you have anything
like that i'm
honestly
it's
the conversations are a dialogue with
the people i'm speaking with so it's
about consent on both parts of the
conversation so we're just vibing each
other out and feeling i feel their
discomfort i'm not a sicko i'm not a
sociopath i can feel the energy and so
we i push as far as we want to go and
then i pull back so how much is actually
on the cards that you're holding and how
much is planned out i improvise a lot
yeah but we have a lot of we have
writers a great team of um joe firestone
and michelle and ike who is in the first
episode of ronald i'm missing taggart
but i improvise a lot of questions you
know but i this is what i like about
what you do you ask these questions and
you do these skits with straight faces
just like you did with elon musk you did
a thing about climate change and saving
the penguin so you said i need to learn
stripping so i can help the penguins and
somebody said why are you doing this she
said because i want to help the penguins
and you ask slim your instructor why are
you doing it and she said for for
benjamin franklin i mean it's just stuff
like that that's just throughout the
show that is really very well done i
mean it's very smart it's very smart
it's it's original in every aspect of it
and people just need to watch it like
enough of us talking about it like tune
in
i really it's it's very very different
well we see you at the white house press
correspondent are you there what are you
looking forward to it's your first time
what am i looking forward to i'm looking
forward to all of the future iconic
guests that will be there
i'm going to meet and shake their hands
in person right well president invited
well done future iconic guests one of
your guests called you a b-list
coming up next a look at all that matter
this week we'll be right back